good morning believe nation today we're
going to talk about why hard work beats
talent right leaf Andre we're Brian
Bosworth Purvis Ellison
think about these things do you know
them a lot of you don't these are guys
that were drafted very high in sports
very very high Sam Bowie drafted before
Michael Jordan can we get over the point
of people thinking that talent is enough
like even contact which is the most
powerful thing which is you know if you
have talent you can pump it out this
whole notion of business that you know
you can't out hustle or outwork somebody
to be better than them is insanity
anybody that follows sports and
especially if they follow drafts in any
way at all
Akili Smith that energy numerated I mean
seriously
anybody who follows sports and drafts
and any shape or form that doesn't
understand that I don't give a rat's ass
if you're a better writer or if you can
pump out better videos and if you're not
willing to out work and love it have a
passion for it then you're gonna get
beat by somebody who's not as good and
absolutely doesn't have the talent that
you have but it's gonna make a whole lot
more money have a whole lot more
opportunity I think the line in the sand
the defining thing in this whole game is
hustle and I wanted to pitch you that
picture because I got a lot of you know
those athletes I want you to understand
just gorge anybody I want you to
understand okay I don't care I want
people to understand that somebody's
gonna outwork you I'm definitely an
outwork you and there's other people are
gonna outwork you in your niche and if
you don't start putting in the hours and
stop dropping if you want to start
dropping the Xbox controller and they'll
be paddle and your TiVo remote and that
beer after work
your hands you know Luis I don't give a
rat's ass if you went to Yale or you're
the most creative son of a baby you know
trying to fix the person with me shut up
you [ __ ] if you're the biggest you know
best of all time but you don't put in
the work in the hustle you're gonna get
beat and businesses that don't care and
have a little small startups like Arab
or they're gonna beat you too do you
know somebody that's very talented and
yet they just don't seem to be
successful I I can tell you I know a lot
of people like that and I'll bet right
now you in your own mind have the
picture of somebody that just fits that
description they have a lot of gifts
they have a lot of talent but they never
take off and you kind of say how could
they be so gifted and yet be so average
well I think I discovered the answer and
so I wrote a book about it and titled
talent is never enough and basically the
thesis of the book is that no matter how
talented you are
talent alone won't get you at the top
and yet I know a whole bunch of people
who somehow think that talent is a train
that they can ride to the top and they
don't have to do anything else and one
day they'll be there in the book talent
is never enough I talk about things that
you and I can choose that we have
control over that will be a plus to the
talent that we have you see talent is
god-given I don't take any claim to my
talent as far as I worked hard to have
it I'm Who I am because that's who I how
I was made so talent is not something I
could even kind of lay claim to but the
choices I make beside my talent now that
is a difference for example in the book
I talk about belief lifts our talent now
belief is a choice my ability to believe
in myself but even my team believed in
my project belief is a lifter of talent
I can choose to believe in myself I can
choose to invest in me I've never really
viewed myself as particularly talented
view myself as you know slightly above
average in talent and where I excel is
ridiculous
sickening work ethic you know while the
other guys sleeping I'm working while
the other guys eaten I'm working you can
look at the the first six episodes of
the The Fresh Prince and I was so just
hell-bent on not failing that I
memorized the entire script and you can
see in certain shots they tried to cut
around it as much as they can but I am
mouthing the other actors lines if you
don't believe it watch the scene with a
young Don Cheadle but keep your eyes on
Smith Freddy Krueger's they have
nightmares about it it took six episodes
for for someone to tell me to stop doing
it so then the next six episodes look
like oh come on Uncle Phil I'm serious
stop playing for me you know what I
believe hard work pays off you know when
you say it's been a it's been my year
and it's it's my time you know Hollywood
has a way of making everything seem like
overnight success oh my god where'd this
guy come from oh this kid who is he look
yeah there's a massive star 18 years in
the business you know put it I'll put in
my time you know I got I got dues that
that have been paid and paid again and
paid one more time after that I stayed
true to my dreams and by doing that
eventually they came true I remain I'm
uninterested in that topic mom which one
whether the relationship between gift
and practice no I'm gonna trust it in
natural gifts yeah I know they exist and
I know there's such a thing as talent
but it's neither that but right I just
feel like so and so what right because
there are people and I always think of
your Vasko if an Iowa sake of Derrick
Coleman yes I remember chatting with a
guy who worked for the Sixers and he
said you have to understand the Derrick
Coleman was the most gifted man ever to
set foot on a basketball court I always
believed that Knoxville talent can take
you so far but I think you need to have
the work ethic and the drive to to
achieve your potential I mean I'd say
you know my natural talent you know
probably brought me
50% of the way but then after that it
was all it was all done the work that
I've done and the volume of work that
I've done over the you know the last 15
years you know when I really started to
take go seriously and you know thought
about you're making this a career so to
make the complete player how much of it
is practice and how much of it is
natural talent
of course the talents is part of me but
if you don't work the talent you're
never going to achieve that things that
I'm achieve so I try to do my things to
improve myself in the training
specifically specifically in the games
because this is the most important thing
so I always try to to improve something
season by season I'm gonna play yourself
okay so this is this is my thing when
when people go oh oh you so talented you
were born with natural talent no no no
listen to this right this is this is the
have you as this been played in public
before no okay so this is our such an
exclusive a cheering when he was [ __ ]
basically basically basically
intelligent when when people say artists
are born with talent you know you have
to you have to really learn and really
practice this is me playing guitar and
singing I'm gonna put in to promote this
okay so
Oh
today
by this practice after that you practice
I did yeah no I just I probably needed
it thank you guys so much for watching
I made this edition of believe life
because Levi Howard asked me to so if
there's a topic that you want me to
cover in the next edition of believe
life leaving the comments below and I'll
see what I can do I love the comments
coming in so thank you for those
suggestions I'd also love to know which
of the clips that you saw today
resonated with you the most leaving the
comments I'll join the discussion thank
you so much for watching have an amazing
day continue to believe and we'll see
you soon